anteriormente vimos como escribir la
expresión de equilibrio entonces si
tenemos un ácido general h
que le done a un protón al h2o el h2o se
transforma en h 3 o más y h
se convierte en la base conjugada a
menos así que esta es nuestra expresión
de equilibrio donde la constante de
acidez k a para un ácido débil debe de
ser menor a 1 aquí tenemos 3 ácidos
débiles ácido clorhídrico ácido acético
y metanol de este lado tenemos los
valores de k
observen que el ácido clorhídrico tiene
el más alto 3.5 por 10 a la menos 4 es
más grande que 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
así que aún cuando se consideran ácidos
débiles
sido flor hídrico es más fuerte que el
ácido acético y el ácido acético es más
fuerte que el metanol
pero ahora hablemos del pk y el pk
es igual a menos el logaritmo de k
entonces si queremos saber el pk del
metanol simplemente calculamos el menos
logaritmo de azúcar
entonces el pk del metanol es igual a
menos logaritmo de 2.9 por 10 a la menos
16 usemos la calculadora menos logaritmo
de 2.9 por 10 a la menos 16 es igual a
si lo redondeamos 15.54 entonces el pk
del metanol es igual a 15.54 vamos a
escribir la columna de pk as para el
metanol es de 15.50 y 4 y si hacemos lo
mismo para el ácido acético el resultado
es de 4.74 y el pk
para el ácido clorhídrico es de 3.46
observen que conforme subimos en la
tabla aumenta la fuerza del ácido por
eso dentro de estos 3 ácidos débiles el
ácido clorhídrico es el más fuerte tiene
el valor más alto de acá
pero observen que tiene el valor más
pequeño de pk y entonces a menor pk a
más ácido es el compuesto 3
punto 46 es menor a 4 punto 74 así que
el ácido fluorhídrico es más ácido que
el ácido acético
el problema nos pide que calculemos el
ph de una solución 1 molar de vinagre
que es ácido acético en agua empecemos
escribiendo la reacción ácido base
tenemos ácido acético de h3c o h más
agua y si el ácido acético dona un
protón al agua el agua se transforma en
h 3 o más el johnny drone y también nos
queda el ion acetato de h3c o menos que
es la base conjugada del ácido acético
ahora antes de entrar al problema
supongamos que iniciamos con 100
moléculas de ácido acético
100 moléculas y supongamos que al inicio
ninguna de ellas ha reaccionado
eso significa que todavía no tenemos
productos no tiene emoción es idóneo ni
aniones acetato como el ácido acético es
un ácido débil recordemos que un ácido
fuerte ioniza el 100 por ciento es decir
todas estas 100 moléculas pero como el
ácido acético es un ácido débil
supongamos que sólo una de las moléculas
dona un protón al agua así que perdemos
una molécula de ácido acético que se
convertirá en una unión aceptar entonces
si perdemos una molécula de ácido
acético ganamos una de añón acetato y
por lo tanto si protón amos una molécula
de agua entonces ganamos una de johnny
drone ya así que en total
tendríamos 99 moléculas de ácido acético
una molécula de idron yo y una de
acetato entonces así es cómo aplicaremos
la concentración vamos con el problema
empecemos con la concentración inicial
empezamos con una solución 1 molar de
ácido acético así que escribimos 1.00
como nuestra concentración inicial y
nuevamente supongamos que como todavía
no ocurre la reacción la concentración
de iones hidronew es 0 y la
concentración de acetato también es cero
ahora vamos a escribir una c para el
cambio y vamos a definir x como la
concentración de ácido acético qué
reacción entonces si perdemos una
concentración x de ácido acético
ganaremos esa misma concentración de
iones acetato y por lo tanto también
ganamos esa concentración de iones
sidronio
cuando la reacción llega al equilibrio
la concentración para el ácido acético
es de 1.00 - x después la concentración
de iones sidronio es equis y la
concentración de añón es acetato también
es x ahora escribamos nuestra expresión
de equilibrio k a es igual a la
concentración de iones sidronio h 3 o
más por la concentración de iones
acetato todo esto entre la concentración
de ácido acético porque no tomamos en
cuenta el agua
ácido acético
la concentración el equilibrio de iones
sidronio es x entonces tenemos x
la concentración de añón es acetato que
también es x x y todo esto entre la
concentración de ácido acético al
equilibrio que es 1 - x entonces 1.00
menos x
esto es igual al k del ácido acético que
tenemos en la tabla anterior vamos a ver
este es el k para el ácido acético 1.8
por 10 a la menos 5 entonces vamos a
escribirlo 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 ahora
calculemos x tendríamos que usar la
fórmula cuadrática pero podemos hacer
una suposición para que sea más fácil
supongamos que la concentración x es
mucho menor a 1 molar esto nos facilita
mucho el cálculo porque si x
es mucho más pequeño que uno entonces 1
- x es aproximadamente igual a uno
porque x al ser tan pequeño no hay mucha
diferencia en restarlo a uno y entonces
supongamos que uno menos x es igual a
uno y nos queda 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
es igual a equis cuadrada sobre 1 usemos
la calculadora tenemos raíz cuadrada de
1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 es igual a 0.00
42 entonces x es igual a 0.00 42 y
recordemos que x representa la
concentración de iones sidronio al
equilibrio entonces esto es igual a la
concentración de iones y drones
finalmente calculemos el ph de la
solución que es lo que nos piden en el
problema el ph es igual a menos el
logaritmo de la concentración de iones y
drone ya que es de 0.00 42 entonces
usemos la calculadora menos logaritmo de
0.00 42 es igual a 2.38 nuestro ph es
igual a 2.38 este es el ph de la
solución de vinagre